well we do think that inflation is going
to fall quite rapidly
we're almost from well from the next
release onwards which is during two
weeks and the reason for that is
well no not rapidly we did think that
some more was going to come out but the
the rapid the rapid sort of fall starts
it's a rather mechanical point but it's
the big annual increases of this time
last year that start to fall out of the
annual calculation it's really to do
with Energy prices and to wait until the
way the off-chem process worked a year
ago so that's you know that's the thing
that's going to change and that doesn't
happen until the April data which will
come out um in in a couple of weeks time
so that's that's that's what we expect
to happen the economy has been more
resilient I think that's that's good
news I think there's a number of reasons
for that
um Energy prices of course have come
down a lot which has eased the cost of
living from that point of view
um
fiscal policy is more supportive after
the budget and the world economy is more
supportive China's got out of its you
know zero covert policy with less
disruption than we feared so there's
some good news there but it seems like
you know a lot of people uh looking at
the headlines here they'll have seen
this you know biggest upgrade from the
bank in in a long time for the economic
growth numbers but they will be filling
they'll be feeling some the squeeze and
the squeeze is intensifying and it's
intensifying in part because of what the
bank is doing which is Raising interest
rates yes and there's more of that pain
to come through for a lot of households
in terms of what they're going to be
feeling with their interest rates coming
up is that right well and the reason for
that is that the mortgage Market has
changed a lot uh in the what now nearly
20 years actually since there was the
previous real tightening cycle of
interest rates with interest rates going
up so of course we now have a much more
fixed rate dominated mortgage Market I
think around about 85 percent of
mortgages in this country are now set
over a period obviously it can be you
know two years upwards but five seven
years what it means though is that these
you know the
mortgage costs are just
a bit more slowly sometimes uh you know
it there is obviously depending on the
mix of mortgages we have but it's coming
through more slowly now we factor that
in because we know that by the end of
this year there will be a lot more
mortgages that will reset because fixed
rates for millions of households and so
we yeah but we factor and we factored
that in but that's so how much of the
pain have we had so far on that and how
much has yet to come
well we think
in terms of in terms of resetting an
adjustment is probably normal about a
third possibly come from only a third so
far obviously by the way it's a bit more
complicated because obviously as we
raise rates then it yeah yeah but just
in terms so there is still two-thirds of
the kind of interest rate related pains
yet to come there's quite a large number
of quite a large proportion of mortgages
yet to reset and just looking more
broadly at what's happened you know to
the economy are the British people
poorer as a result of what we're going
through right now well I think we have
to be careful with the choice of words
here
what we've had is because so much of
this inflation is coming from external
sources and there you know there's two
huge shocks been going on in the world
we've had the largest you know the
biggest Global pandemic for 100 years
we've had sadly well both of them are
sad we've had the largest war in Europe
since Second World War
now that has caused an increase in the
price of things we import
it's caused a reduction in our real
national income because of that and that
comes through with higher inflation
higher inflation from the things that we
import
that has reduced national income we
can't I'm afraid make that go away we
have to deal with it so national income
so they are poorer as a result and we
are very sensitive to the fact of the
impact this has is reducing our national
income and I'm very sensitive to that
and I'm also I'm very sensitive to the
fact that because it's so concentrated
in what I call the essentials of life
and energy food
that it affects those less well-off
households more because they have a
bigger share of their consumption in
those Essentials because it's because
for a lot of people again you know
they're looking at you in this kind of
guilt-edged room in the in in the middle
of London and up around the country
people are really struggling right now
do you do you see that and relate with
that I do and I'm very very sensitive to
this fact that this shock has reduced
our national income
through higher inflation
and and say I'm afraid the bank of
England doesn't have a tool to make that
go away
we can't make help well what we have to
do is stop it becoming persistent right
but can you help with particularly some
families who are you know particularly
struggling right now some people don't
have mortgages you know some people have
lots of savings actually there's been
not bad relatively speaking for some
people but for some people it really has
been quite tough so can you can you kind
of focus on those people and really help
well I think it's not something I'm
afraid that monetary policy can can
address because monetary policy is an
economy-wide tool I have to be so it's
not for the benefits
it's not for me to prescribe what others
others should do in that situation I
think it's you know it's for others to
use policy tools uh as appropriate and
that's an appropriate policy process
what is crucial is that we use monetary
policy to prevent it becoming persistent
because it yeah the hardest thing I have
to say is that makes it worse the final
thing you know today you're talking
about the fact that food price inflation
has been higher than expected you've had
to upgrade or raise your inflation
forecast before it was you know before
it was energy
people are looking at the bank they're
looking at your inflation forecast and
they're saying you keep getting it wrong
I mean is is the simple truth here that
basically the bank isn't very good at
forecasting
I don't agree with that
um I I want to be very clear we are
having you know we're experiencing huge
external shocks coming into can we not
alone in this I mean other countries
obviously have got the same situation
those external shocks are frankly not
something you can forecast as such
things like the war what's the war you
can't forecast War the public was
missing its forecast before the war it
was missing its forecasts before the big
the big rise because there was because
there was an impact from 2021 there was
an impact from covid on on what we said
called Supply chains on on the supply of
goods into into the into the world
economy actually now that was the first
shock we dealt with sort of post-covered
what I think has been particularly
difficult in this situation is that
we've had this succession of big shocks
with no gaps in between and we've had to
deal with those and we've had to adapt
policy as those shocks and their effects
have come along and I also would fully
recognize we learn things about those
shocks as they go on so the transmission
of food prices it's going to take longer
for it to work through it's not that it
is going to become persistent in the
sense of never going away we all the
food producers and retailers so I talked
to say no it is going to come down this
year but it is taking longer that I
think has some things to do with the
nature of the shocks that we're
experiencing and yeah particularly I'm
afraid sadly how the war in Ukraine has
fed through into elements of the world
economic system because you're pretty
sure you've got it tweaked now we can
trust you now on the inflation forecasts
well
we are the very sort of firmly behind
the view we have now which is why we've
changed we've moved rates today
I've been very clear though that you
know our future actions will be driven
by the evidence that's very clear and
the evidence will move on I hope the
evidence will show inflation as I expect
inflation starts to come down quite
sharply and that this resilience in the
economy continues because that is
helpful